la toscane une des régions les plus
visités d'italie
ses paysages somptueux attire chaque
année 10 millions de touristes au coeur
de la toscane sienne la ville aux 17
quartiers
[Musique]
chaque année depuis des siècles sur la
piazza del campo ces quartiers
s'affrontent dans une course de chevaux
effréné
le week-end
bâté kolé
cette course le palio est ici une
véritable institution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque siennois descendent dans la rue
pour défendre son cheval son quartier et
son emblème
[Applaudissements]
cet après midi c'est la prima prova le
premier entraînement des chevaux sur la
piste un moment crucial pour tester les
capacités du cheval depuis quatre
siècles les règles du palio sont les
mêmes c'est simple il n'y en a pas la
course est d'une grande intensité et
elle est surtout très dangereuse non
lanka et l'a donc à la batterie qui
reflète la pâle telle est la loupe à la
boule va nous sommes tous les coups sont
permis et même à l'entraînement
les chutes sont fréquents chez les mots
et des phrases
jean paul ii
ce soir le premier cheval qui tombe et
celui de l'oca le quartier de loi ces
quotas de relations et à la même date
et quelques minutes plus tard c'est
celui de la ccio piola le quartier de
l'escargot
une chute très impressionnante qui
provoque la stupeur
[Musique]
voyons
on est là
sitôt la course terminée le jockey est
évacué gravement blessé il ne pourra pas
participer à la course
les supporteurs de l'escargot se
précipite sur la piste pour aller aux
nouvelles du jockey
m
d
pp
papa cool pour l'escargot le palio est
terminée par contre le jockey du
quartier de loi a eu plus de chance
il s'en tire indemne
las
nous sommes dans le quartier de la tibet
tard le quartier de la chouette en plein
centre-ville
giuseppe à 49 ans il est chauffeur de
taxi il participe au palio depuis 25 ans
ce soir un grand banquet est organisé
pour les supporters de la tri bêta on
devrait être environ 1000 au dîner
c'est le quartier le plus petit le
quartier vit toute l'année
le palio c'est le point culminant de
l'année
tout tourne autour du palio et du
quartier c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'intérieur une sensation que l'on a en
soi c'est la beauté d'être tous ensemble
il n'ya plus l'échelle sociale plus
d'âge il n'existe plus rien
pour
[Musique]
c'est la beauté d'être ensemble c'est
une grande famille
comme tous les ans les habitants de la
cchit bêta croit dur comme fer en leur
victoire la dernière fois qu'ils ont
gagné c'était en 2009
personne ici n'a oublié cet événement
cela faisait trente ans qu'ils
attendaient cette victoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le film c'est le film de notre victoire
du palio en 2009 un film qu'on a tous
appelés 11000 un jour après parce qu'on
a compté les jours et il s'est passé
exactement onze mille un jour depuis la
victoire du 4 juillet 1979 est là et là
on vient de comprendre qu on a gagné on
l'a vu des millions de fois
à chaque fois ils veulent tous aller
prendre le drapeau de la victoire à
chaque fois ses parts à chaque fois
c'est très émouvant
avant la course du lendemain comme le
veut la tradition les habitants de la
cub états se réunissent tous pour un
banquet géant les femmes festoient d'un
côté et les hommes de löw
[Applaudissements]
c'est
la ville avant tout jamais seul pour ne
même pas à cacher
[Applaudissements]
générationnel lino de la vodka cassée
[Musique]
et ça
et
et toi
auj
[Musique]
ça
ce soir un homme est à l'honneur le
jockey
tout le monde est venu pour le voir et
surtout entendre son discours
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
il
vous m'avez donné le courage la force de
rentrer dans les écuries
j'ai parlé avec des amis et j'ai compris
combien le palio est important pour la
tu vas tu as vous m'avez accueilli
vous m'avez ému jusqu'aux larmes alors
je vous dis que je n'ai qu'un seul but
demain celui de revenir ici devant vos
yeux remplis de larmes de joie parce
qu'on leur a gagné une nouvelle fois le
palio je vous le jure je vous le jure de
tout mon être
merci
il prononce léman que tout le monde veut
entendre il promet la victoire
là
il faut
hier
la course tant attendue le palio doit
avoir lieu dans quelques heures mais il
y à une invitée inattendue la pluie pire
que ça c'est un énorme orage de grêle
qui s'abat sur la ville
[Musique]
la déconvenue est totale l'inquiétude
aussi comment les chevaux vont ils
pouvoir courir sur une piste boueuse et
glissante
le palio et les cérémonies vont ils être
annulé pour l'instant la confusion est
totale
mais malgré la pluie dans le quartier de
la cchit bêta on a décidé de continuer
comme si de rien n'était car le moment
est d'importance le curé du quartier va
bénir le jockey et le cheval
ça
protège et défend aujourd'hui et
toujours ton serviteur andréa do tout
danger de tout calamité au nom de
saint-antoine de saint bernard et de
jésus christ notre seigneur
[Musique]
que dieu tout puissant te bénisse au nom
du père du fils et du saint-esprit va et
revient victorieux
après la bénédiction les chevaux et
leurs palefrenier des filtres une
dernière fois à travers les rues du
centre ville avant de faire une entrée
triomphale sur la piazza del campo
sur la place pas moins de cinquante
mille personnes sont venues assister à
la course
pour être aux premières loges les
appartements qui donne sur la piazza del
campo sont particulièrement convoités
[Musique]
quinze jours
- mettez la cravate
pour le temps de la course ces
appartements sont loués à prix d'or à
des sociétés qui invitent leurs
meilleurs clients
nous avons préparé pour nos antennes
une petite présentation du manioc
et aussi pour mieux voir le pas lyon un
petit cadeau
au mieux regarder voilà
ici parmi ces gens nous avons les
présidents de sociétés nous avons aussi
deux représentants de la politique
italienne
si l'opération phénix cher je vous dirai
pas
et laisse christian en fait
l'organisatrice de la soirée aura payé
près de 11000 euros pour assister aux
trois tours de piste des chevaux
dans le quartier de la cchit bêta à
quelques minutes de la course la tension
est palpable
l'honneur du quartier se joue dans un un
sport
[Musique]
dès que le cheval du quartier apparaît
c'est l'euphorie mais aussi l'angoissent
[Applaudissements]
car dans le palio il y a une part de
hasard
les chevaux sont placés par tirage au
sort sur la ligne de départ
un mauvais tirage et c'est la défaite
assurée
et la tib et à part mal en avant
dernière position
[Applaudissements]
la course est menée par le quartier dit
le broco la chenille mais rapidement son
cheval chute
[Applaudissements]
côté
et il n'est pas le seul au même moment
le cheval de la cchit l'état s'écroule
un cataclysme
[Musique]
mais le quartier de lahti bêta n'est pas
encore éliminée car son cheval s'est
relevé il peut encore gagner même sans
son jockey
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement pour la fiv et à cette
année c'est loca le quartier de loi qui
gagne
[Musique]
mais bon
dans le quartier de l'eau car c'est
l'euphorie
les gagnants reçoivent le palio et se
rendre à la basilique de provenzano pour
porter le jockey entrions la cchit bêta
elle doit porter le poids d'une nouvelle
défaite jusqu'à la prochaine course
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]